CHRIS RAMSDALE: Hello, and thank
you for coming aboard
this tour of application
data at Google.
I'm Chris Ramsdale, product
manager for Google App Engine.
I'd like to begin with some
quick trivia to provide some
context for the capabilities and
products I'm going to talk
about today.
Every minute, over 60 hours of
video is uploaded to YouTube.
Google's "Caffeine" Search Index
was over 100 million
gigabytes in June of 2010 and
growing very quickly.
There are over 350 million
active Gmail users.
And it takes Google
approximately one fourth of a
second to respond to
a search query.
So what did Google learn
building these products?
At Google, the reliability and
performance of the systems we
build are critical
to our business.
We realized the traditional data
solutions just wouldn't
do what we needed them to do.
The kind of scale we're talking
about here requires
that we do things differently.
So we spent more than a decade
building data systems that are
extremely reliable and
available, have multiple
layers of redundancy, and can
handle the loss of any given
data center, and are
wicked fast.
We published the details of
our early infrastructure,
MapReduce, Big Table, and the
Google File System, which
became the model that was
adopted by the open source
community that sprung
up around big data.
But those were just
the table stakes.
Whether deliver high-quality
search results, relevant
advertising, or just to learn
how to continually improve our
algorithms and systems, at
Google, we believe fast is
better than slow.
And our focus on performance is
very pervasive through the
systems and products we build.
At the core of our data
offerings are services that
help businesses store and
access their data in the
Google Cloud using the same
technology that we use to run
our business.
Google Cloud Storage for
unstructured content like
files and media, the App Engine
Datastore that provides
a NoSQL environment for
structured data, and Google
Cloud SQL for relational data.
Google's mission is to
organize the world's
information and make it
universally accessible and
useful, which meant that we got
very good at finding out
the meaning of data and
doing so very quickly.
As the business and data
landscapes have evolved, some
of the problems that we set
out to solve that seemed
fairly specialized to our
business are now pervasive in
the industry.
Data is a core business asset,
becoming ever more important
as a competitive advantage.
There are fewer and fewer
low-hanging fruit.
At the same time, data is
growing faster than most
organizations' ability to
leverage or even capture it.
Going from a few gigabytes to
several terabytes to petabytes
of data has fundamentally
changed the tools
needed to work it.
And traditional BI is struggling
to keep up.
Several commercial and open
source initiatives have sprung
up to solve these problems,
many of which are based on
technical papers that Google
wrote to share its innovations
with the world.
Hadoop is based on Google's
MapReduce technical paper,
HDFS on the Google
File System, and
HBase on Big Table.
In the years since we published
those technical
papers, our technology has
continued to evolve.
And now, we're starting to make
our latest and greatest
data tools available as
cloud-based services.
In the Google Cloud, you can
use App Engine to build
scalable web applications
with high productivity
and low time to market.
Google BigQuery lets you unlock
the insights hidden in
large data sets.
And the Google Prediction API
enables you to use Google's
machine learning technology
with your data.
Beyond storing and accessing
your data, though, we're
really focused on making that
data useful through an
integrated platform of data
services, premium APIs, and
platform services that let you
store, analyze, and leverage
your data in your own
applications.
I'll talk a bit more about
leveraging your data in the
Google Cloud in a
little while.
Let's first look at the
core data services.
First, Google Cloud Storage.
This product was built from
the ground up to store
unstructured data with high
reliability, availability, and
performance, and to allow you to
seamlessly scale your data
as your needs grow.
Data is stored with multiple
levels of redundancy for high
availability and performance.
One of the many benefits of
using Google Cloud Storage is
that you put Google's network
to work for you.
When you store your data in the
cloud, you quickly realize
that cloud services live
and die by the network.
That's been an area of
significant investment by
Google, and we think it shows
in the quality of service.
At high scale, reliable
storage has many
uses in and of itself.
In order of increasing value,
you can use it as a tape
replacement strategy for
your data backups.
Use it for active archives,
storing your data archives in
the cloud for easy access and
no maintenance overheads.
You can use it for all kinds of
content and media-serving
applications to quickly and
easily share data with the
organization, with a small or
large group of external
partners or customers, or freely
over the internet.
You can use it to store data
for your applications or in
conjunction with some of our
other services for analysis
and computation.
When most people think about
their structured data
strategy, they think about
two kinds of products.
NoSQL datastores that offer a
very high scale and support
for millions of queries per
second, usually in exchange
for less rich data
representation--
typically they're denormalized
data--
and/or tradeoffs in
data consistency.
SQL-based data stores that are
well-suited for applications
that need relational data, but
cannot deliver the kind of
global scale and performance
that NoSQL stores can.
At Google, we believe that
each has its own place.
The App Engine high-replication
Datastore is
based on Google's Megastore
technology and combines the
scalability and performance
benefits of a NoSQL data store
with high availability,
transactional capabilities, a
flexible query engine, and
strong consistency guarantees.
The Datastore is schemeless,
which means your data
structure can be flexible and
evolve with your needs.
Unlike many NoSQL solutions,
it doesn't sacrifice
consistency.
It offers the ability to perform
asset operations
within transactions and
consistent reads outside.
It's a very reliable
service, too.
Data is written to multiple
data centers, making it
capable of withstanding multiple
data center failures.
That replication Datastore has
had 100% uptime since its
launch a year ago.
But to get all these benefits,
you do need to think
differently.
You can't use tools
that depend on
traditional SQL databases.
You need to denormalize
your data.
These tradeoffs make the
Datastore most suitable for
data sets that need to scale
seamlessly and deliver high
performance and availability.
For those applications that do
not need the kind of scale
that the Datastore provides
and that benefit from the
ability to use a traditional
database, we recently launched
Google Cloud SQL as an
experimental service that is
open for public use.
This new service gives you a
fully managed MySQL database
in the Google Cloud.
So you can use more traditional
tools and
represent your relational
data effectively.
The data is replicated
for availability.
Once your data is in the cloud,
you can make use of
other Google technologies.
BigQuery is a fully hosted cloud
data analysis service
that enables you to get
critical insights from
multiterabyte data sets at
near real-time speeds.
It's built on Google's
infrastructure based on
production tools used by Google
to build its own big
data business.
You can perform SQL-like queries
via UI or API to gain
insights from your data, share
and distribute them, build
your application dashboards,
et cetera.
It offers some unique
benefits.
You can find a needle
in a haystack.
Tens of terabytes.
You can get near-instant results
in unlimited scale.
No maintenance and no long-term
commitments needed.
We think that BigQuery
represents a discontinuity in
what you can do with data.
You can reduce time to insight
from weeks to minutes,
allowing your business
to move faster.
You can get straight to business
insights without
building and maintaining a
data center, developing
specialized technical
capabilities, or licensing
expensive software.
You don't need to build
indexes to do
traditional BI planning.
So you can be more flexible.
Because, let's face it, it's
practically impossible to know
all the questions you'll
need to ask beforehand.
For when you need to build
data-centric applications, we
offer Google App Engine, which
lets you build internet-scale
applications quickly, easily,
and cost-effectively.
You only pay for the resources
you use, which means you don't
need to do complex capacity
planning or keep large amounts
of rarely used buffer
capacity on hand.
The data generated by your
applications can be quickly
analyzed using Google Cloud
Storage and BigQuery.
App Engine is also a great way
to build applications that
provide reporting, dashboarding,
and other
capabilities to your business,
your partners,
or even your customers.
I'd like to spend a couple of
minutes talking about a few
illustrative cases where people
have leveraged Google's
technology to power
their data.
DNAnexus is a bay area-based
company focused on unlocking
the potential of DNA-based
medicine and biotechnology
with a collaborative and
scalable data technology
platform built on the cloud.
They wanted to give researchers
around the world
tools to search for and
access sequence read
archive data sets.
They had an ambitious goal--
to completely re-engineer how
researchers interacted with
the data, mine results,
and download
data sets of interest.
By using Google Cloud Storage
to store and serve the data,
they were able to quickly build
a web-based interface to
the SRA data sets that had
garnered praise from the
research community.
Crystalloids is an
Amsterdam-based analytics firm
that helps businesses analyze
massive amounts of data to
improve profitability.
They first used Google BigQuery
and Cloud Storage to
provide a customized product
for one of their customers.
Based on their success with this
project, they launched
Crystalloids Innovations,
a subsidiary that offers
cloud-based tools to the retail
and hospitality industry.
Daffodil Software provides
a suite of web-based
applications, including a
business customer relationship
management--
otherwise known as CRM--
program and an enterprise
resource planning--
ERP--
app for schools.
Daffodil needed a cloud-based
hosting platform for its
applications that would
save money and time
over in-house hosting.
They built their applications
using Google App Engine and
Google Cloud SQL.
So in conclusion, you can now
put Google's technology to
work for you.
You can store and access your
structured and unstructured
data, mine your data for
insights, and build new
applications and capabilities
quickly and effectively.
In return, you can capture more
data, gain business and
competitive advantages by
unlocking insights in data
sets of any size.
And you can do so
cost-effectively.
Thanks for watching.
I hope this helps you understand
how you can use
Google's infrastructure to store
your applications' data
and power your business.
For more information,
be sure to check out
developers.google.com.